good evening councillors
ladies and gentlemen and welcome to the
spiritual meeting of council
and unfortunately my chaplain father
gerald murphy
can't be with us this evening so
apologies for that and
all members of council have been invited
to attend this meeting electronically
and i have received apologies for
absence from councillors mrs churchill
lolly councillor shaw and can i ask
are there are we aware of any other
apologies
so just those three apologies at the
moment council mrs churchill council
audience counselor sure
um we've got quite a few members
uh leaving us this uh this year
this municipal year and in fact it's
their last meeting
and can i say on behalf of myself and
the council
thank you to all those members for their
service for the time they've been here
thank you for that and good luck in the
future and i think
the leader would like to comment leader
thank you chair just to just to echo
your words of thanks really but there
are some particularly
um senior members stepping down this
time it would be remiss of me not to
comment both on all members um who are
going but also in particular on a couple
of those and so i think i'm correct
um although one or two have been
somewhat corey about this or been
keeping it under wraps that we've got
um councilman uh leaving us after five
years i think um
from hail central we have councillor
shaw
stepping down who's not with us tonight
um
i think councillor churchill um is
is going after just two years i hope
that's that's nothing that we did but i
i'm sure she'll be missed by
um the residents of bowdoin but i do
just want to reflect um
in a little more um detail on on three
members in particular who are stepping
down mr mayor
the first would be councillor rigby um
who who obviously has served russian
upon mercy ward for
and indeed its predecessor mercy saint
mary's for
27 years i believe um and obviously
has given great service not only to the
council but
to education in the borough in
particular and was
rightly awarded the mbe for his for his
work in
in that field brian and i were on the
employment committee together many moons
ago and i've always found him somebody
who who's been really easy to work with
regardless of
um party politics and and obviously
somebody who's had a long career
in public service as a retired police
officer the second is
a very very dear friend of mine who i
don't think is on the call and has
struggled technically since the
transition to zoom which is councillor
whit stenit
who um obviously has given um even
longer service to the council 28 years
representing residents in clifford ward
and whit is really
an old trafford legend he has given
incredible service not only to this
council
but i but i think his community and old
trafford in particular he too
has been recognized with the mbe but
also
for specific recognition for his
services to the west indian community
in greater manchester and beyond whit is
somebody who has
taught me an incredible amount quite a
quiet man
in in many ways but a very thoughtful
and intelligent one and a committed
socialist
um too and i and i know um the that
all of us wish wish him well as he um
steps down from the council but the
final the final person that i just
wanted to mention specifically was was
councillor amnesty
um and i say that um as somebody who was
um paid for many years to oppose
councillor amstee
um and that was a job that i'm not gonna
lie i quite enjoyed doing for the years
that i did it but
that was because um we were never afraid
to get stuck into each other
to do the job but also at the end of
these meetings another public forum to
have a chat perhaps grab a pint talk
things through
somebody who was always very open and
honest in his dealings with me and
whether
i agreed with anything he ever did and
once or twice i did but generally not so
much
um i always understood that he was doing
what he thought was best for
for the people at trafford i i know
after three years
in the role that this is an incredibly
difficult job but i know the commitment
and passion he has
um for our borough and i know that he
will continue to
work for what is best for the people of
trafford in his relatively new role as
chair of thc
and i'm sure that we wish him um well in
the future just to say
mr mayor on a final point as well that
um councillor shirley proctor
will be stepping down as a councillor
tomorrow
um and that's uh shirley's stepping down
for personal reasons after just two
years on the council and i know that
um if things have been different she
would have been hoping to to stay but in
those couple of years she has
represented her residence in blixton
wood very diligently and as with all
members
um i'm sure that we wish her all the
very best for the future
and i'm i'm apologizing for taking so
much time to do that
um chair but the you know the the
seniority of some of the members that
are stepping down in the incredible
service of all of those members i hope
you'll forgive me for
just taking a few minutes there to place
on record
my thanks and tributes to all of them
thanks very much
thank you councillor weston i think
that's very appropriate we need to spend
time
thanking those members for their service
um
following yesterday's national day of
reflection marking the anniversary of
the first
coveted lockdown may i ask the council
to pause for a few moments to reflect on
events over the last 12 months
and remember all those who have very
subtly died during the pandemic
512 of which have been here in trafford
but i propose we have a minute silence
please everybody
so
thank you everybody may i remind you of
a few house rules when participating in
tonight's virtual relent
meeting please remember to mute your
microphone when not speaking
to use the chat facility to indicate to
the chair that you wish to speak
and only use a chat facility for that
purpose and to unmute your microphone
when invited
by the chair to speak and can he
introduce uh
an extra rule uh this evening um
for this evening's meeting and for
future meetings can i ask that members
address me
as mayor or chair um
i'm grateful to the green party members
who've been doing this
just that for some time now i think a
general neutral term is more fitting
in this day and age i don't think that's
too difficult for everybody and
it makes certain makes sense to me um
but if anybody does slip out with a mr
mayor comment that's fine
i won't promise not to get into a hoof
but uh for my term of office certainly i
would like to be known as
uh mayor or chair please and not mr may
thank you
[Music]
i'll just for that everybody i don't
think was on screen but i think you all
heard
what i had to say
also tonight on those items where a vote
is called for
we will use the polling option at the
appropriate time i will announce that i
am putting the matter to the vote
window will appear on your screen and
you'll be asked to click on one of the
three options available
either for or against abstain once you
have selected your preference
please click submit at the bottom of the
window and the outcome of the vote will
appear on the screen
once all votes are in finally
since we are hosting the meeting
virtually should we encounter any
technical difficulties it may be
necessary to adjourn in the first
instance for 15 minutes
an update and rejoining instructions
will be emailed to members
if we are unable to broadcast a meeting
live on youtube
we would hope to upload a recording at a
later date
evans would like to speak councillor
evans uh please feel free to
speak thank you mr mayor it was just we
we've got some um
excellent counsellors with excellent uh
experience
leaving tonight and i did feel it would
be remiss of me not to i'll keep i'll
try and keep it brief
and you know we are losing three former
mayors and
a former leader as well as other
councillors so i'll read
i'll keep my comments to the those four
people if i may
sean um when made leader of
our council at 26th the youngest leader
at that time i'd like to pay tribute to
the establishment of the ua 92 the
ongoing regeneration
of ultragun town center and the
transformation of partington with
respect to sean he'll be missed within
the group i'm glad i can call him a
friend
and counselor brian rigby mbe his
support for our schools
for decades absolutely sterling work
and i really i'm just thank him for the
work around the schools amongst many
other things but could go
on and on and on and counselor
whit stenner also mba and
mayor in 2003 2004 and
i don't know him personally but the work
i've seen him do
excellent a superb counsellor superb
advocate for his
um his ward and finally my friend
um and uh guide i suppose uh councillor
robert chilton again
an excellent mayor for the time he was
there and i would just like to
personally thank him for all the work
he's done with me
um over the years i might have
you're shaking your head there andrew i
made a mistake there i didn't know rob
was going it's news to me
i might be wrong i thought he was all
right i think
i mean he would have said something if
he was all right can we can we
get back to the meeting everybody thanks
thank you thanks for those comments
councilor evans thanks a lot
[Music]
first item is a minute and i moved that
the minutes of the meeting held on the
17th of february
2021 be taken and read as a true
and correct record is that seconded
thank you i think it was second did that
um
does the leader of the council wish to
make any announcements this evening
no thank you chad
do the shares of scrutiny have anything
to announce on behalf of their
committees
no thank you chair no no
no mayor thank you thank you i can
report that ten questions have been
submitted for tonight's meeting from
councillors
denise weston heart councillors denise
weston hartley jerome but
mrs haddad welcome brother miss
blackburn
and two from councillor evans each
questioner has the right of a
supplementary question
and all should be put and answered
without discussion we will now take the
questions
in the order they were received question
one
councillor denise weston have you your
first
question
question please for the leader of the
council please could the leader of
advise what steps the council are taking
to support and engage with women to
improve their safety
following the tragic murder of sarah
everard and the series of shocking
sexual assaults
seen here in trafford in recent weeks
including several in my own ward of
broad heath
and furthermore does the leader consider
it appropriate
given these issues to continue with his
proposals
to dim street lights overnight across
the borough
thank you mr mayor
councillor western the questions
addressed to the leader of the council
would you like to respond please thank
you
chair i will yes the proposals to which
um councillor denise western refers were
part of the
annual budget process but following
representations received from several
members of the labour group but in
particular from
the three women councillors representing
broad heath ward last week i did
ask the chief executive and the
corporate director
place to review that and work with the
borough treasurer
to look at ways in which we could
um review that in light of the concerns
over women's safety and i'm pleased to
advise that
we have been able through the
disestablishment of the special projects
fund
to offset the cost
the saving that had been allocated on
street lighting by eliminating that fund
from the council's budget moving forward
meaning that there will be no
cut to street lighting this year and
that that has been done
in a way that is recurrent and meaning
that the saving
is not um simply a one-off that enables
us to
make that change but there was a further
question there which i think is
incredibly important given the
outpouring of um rightful
anger from women about their safety and
about their ability to
make their voices heard on the issue of
sexual violence of sexual assault
and of being able to walk safely in our
communities councillor western is
absolutely correct that a number of
these were in broad heath ward in
particular but they were also dotted
around the borough and several members
as i said have made representations in
this regard
and i have asked councillor slater as
the executive member with responsibility
for equalities to lead a series of
workshops with local women open to
any trafford women that wish to attend
after the election period over a period
of six months so that we are able to
gather as much feedback and engage with
as many
women as possible to listen to and
understand the concerns that they have
around safety and to look at the
interventions that the council working
with partners including the police can
take
to make them feel safer in our
communities and ensure that the concerns
that they have
are are dealt with moving forward
clearly there are limitations in
budgetary terms chair but i
am confident that by prioritizing based
on the feedback that we receive from
women and through the use of target
hardening money and potential grant
funding from greater manchester police
and other sources we will be able to
make some positive steps there and
proactive interventions that will
improve women's safety moving forward
thank you chad
thank you denise weston do you have a
supplementary question
thank you mr mayor i don't have a
supplementary but i would ask that
um you join me um in thanking our local
police
um in resolving the issues we had here
in trafford and making a successful
arrest of the
person responsible thank you
come to denise weston i absolutely agree
with that we do need to thank our police
for their for their work in this uh
serious matter um question two is from
councillor hartley
council thank you mayor
some residents will have read alarming
posts and information
that there might not be sufficient
school places in sale would the lead
member for education like to comment on
this
please would counselor carter lead
member for education like to respond
please thank you chair and thank you
councillor hartley and i have to agree
i too have seen the misinformation and
i'm glad of this opportunity to correct
that
if members were attending or watching
the children young people's scrutiny
meeting last week where this was
discussed
you'll have heard the officer clearly
state that this is not the case
we definitely have enough school places
in sale
i would recommend all members with an
interest
or a desire to write newsletters to read
the school place planning for new
developments paper
that's on the internet to see how places
are calculated
and allocated
thank you councillor carter councillor
hartley do you have a supplementary
question
i i do mayor and yes with your leave
i'll carry on
and ask so um thank you for that answer
councillor carter i mean more
specifically the on the 11th of march
the planning and development management
committee
approved an application for planning
permission to develop the site of the
former trafford magistrates
court with 84 dwellings a high
proportion of which
is going to be family accommodation and
officers calculated the pupil yield
as a result of that development as 14
primary school and
10 secondary school places and that
generated a contribution by the
developer
for that education provision of 439
000 pounds could i ask whether
the council's expansion plans for
schools have taken account of new
developments in the sale area
like the one at trafford magistrates
court and will there be sufficient
capacity
as a result thank you councillor hartley
over the last 10 years trafford has
received 78 million pounds
which has been used to expand 29 schools
and we've created an
additional 3 681
places throughout the borough and it's
quite important to achieve the right
balance between the sufficient places
and over provision because no school
wants to hold vacancies
because it makes it difficult for them
financially but it's important that we
do have places for everyone who wants to
come
so when calculating how many places are
necessary
the team involved have been accurate to
naught 0.1
for primary children and 0.9
for secondary and i know last summer i
did work with a few members who had
concerns that their residents
hadn't got into the school of choice but
i hope you'll all agree that
we reached a good conclusion for all of
these families
and there are occasionally enough
anomalies and i will say
it's more difficult to get a place for a
year 10 child
that arrives mid-term in a certain area
we have to recognize that our secondary
provision in trafford
is extremely popular but if we have more
traffic applications
this means less places for out of
borough children
trafford children are prioritized in our
primary and our non-selective secondary
schools
your question specifically about sale
which is divided into sale
east which is central sail and sell more
and sell west which includes the new
carrington development
um but it's all considered one area when
we look at secondary places
so currently the primaries in sale have
one percent surplus places
and the non-selective secondaries have
three percent circles places
the grammar school is full as this
accounts for 9180 children i think this
is pretty good estimation of the places
needed
and the impact of the 32 development
plans
show that 19 in the sale sale east will
yield 61 children and the 13 in sale
west linked new carrington will yield
276 children we've recently expanded
worthington primary to provide an
additional 15 places
per year and there's room for a further
expansion in that area
and as we discussed at council in
december there's a proposal to create an
additional 30 places per year at the
firs
which subject to statutory processes
will be available from september 2022
and there's also scope for further
expansion in that area if we need it as
well
regarding secondary provision we are
looking at options for secondary places
in sale
and there will be a recommendation
including included in the basic need
report that's coming to executive in
june
2021 but we haven't yet engaged a
specific school or a trust
around which school will um we'll be
seeking to expand
so when we look at places for everyone
which is the new
uh greater manchester spatial framework
both allocation policies recognize the
need for new
educational provision in the areas
that we've mentioned um the new
carrington and the timperley wedge
and as such the developers have been
asked to make a contribution of 6.2
million pounds
towards the expansion or creation of new
schools in these areas
thank you very much chair thank you
question three council jerome please
um sorry
um the a56 from sanctuary the a56 from
silver grove ultringham down to
navigation road has a number of
potholes or defects these cause
vibrations
noise and tremors to houses that bring
great aggravation to residents on a
24-hour basis
would it not be possible for trafford to
prioritize these problems
and spare affected householders
considerable pain across
365 days a year
council ratzer the executive member for
environmental and regulatory services
would you like to respond thank you for
your
question uh councillor jerome as i've
provided you with a
listed answer direct which has also been
placed on the council website
and indeed actually uh to all members as
well would you
and the mayor be happy if i'm if you
move straight to uh
your supplementary would that be
acceptable
i'm happy with that councillor jerome
are you happy with that
yeah thanks chair and thanks councillor
as said for the written answer
and i do have a supplementary question
um residents continually ask
if 20 mile an hour speed limits can be
used to slow lorries
speeding cars and other vehicles hitting
these defects on this dangerous
and bending stretch of road please can
we tell residents
why this can't happen you
for yours excuse me i just followed
something wrong with some water
thank you for your supplementary uh
question councillor jerome
uh and obviously there are particular
problems with speeding vehicles
in in any parts of well then these
obviously do need to be ported to
both the police and indeed the traffic
team you can particularly look at these
concerns around there
spotting a uh particular problem
in any highway but particularly main
roads where you get heavier vehicles is
always a problem
and not necessarily always related speed
i have had numerous in my own bullet
along across
many many roads in that case i think it
is really uh
usually when the traffic is free-flowing
away from particular
congested times and that when they can
actually uh
go straight over them but now the
problem is for some of these they can be
sometimes the width for vehicles it
might be that smaller vehicles
or certain ones can actually go over
without any problems but sure sometimes
that particular
point where the actual vehicles actually
touch points
on the road surface the other vehicles
don't that causes the problems
so i think myself when i'm dealing with
the overall for many years
and i have got i look quite close to 856
as you may be aware
and i live across other votes as well
where we where i would particularly if
we can't always identify them i'll do a
have a site visit
with officers and local residents
obviously if that's take place at home
it will need to be a
covered secure and so forth but that's
the best way to identify particular
problems at this point in time
i would imagine it's one that's always
useful and i think officers can
sometimes dissolve them but sometimes
they can't therefore
a site visit with officers can actually
can sometimes identify them and
sometimes the utilities sometimes
might be some of the things that you've
actually uh highlighted in a message to
me this afternoon
but that they can all be resolved i've
not found an instant where they haven't
been resolved
and the highways officers are always
always quite happy to try and uh support
residents with these problems thank you
thank you councillor ads head counselor
question four is from councillor but
your question please
uh thank you mayor uh yes it was
the question is uh the the the
government recently announced a doubling
of the
safer streets fund to 45 million pounds
in order to provide
file lighting and the greater use of
cctv in parks
can the executive member for environment
regulate and regulatory services state
if the council has received details of
its allocation of its share
of that funding thank you
thank you thank you would you like to
respond
thank you very much for your question
as i have supplied you directly with the
answer yourself
that's and also being placed on the
council website and tour members would
you be happy to go
straight to the uh supplementary or
would you like me to read out the
response thank you
council aboard would you like to no i i
i thank council i'd said for having
responded to that
question which uh stated that the
deputy mayor of greater manchester will
be determining it by
only three bids that will be forwarded
to the the government
so uh and we're unlikely to have
be on the top of the list for for that
so uh
thank you for that response uh by
supplementary
is uh as far as i'm aware other greater
manchester councils are unlikely to
dim their street lights by 20 and delay
when lights come
on and switch off earlier in the morning
will the community safety team in their
conversations with
gmca emphasize that despite having lower
crime rates than other greater
manchester districts
trafford will have more poor poorly lit
streets and therefore should be looked
upon more favorably for the funding
thank you mayor thank you councillor
said
thank you uh and council book for your
supplementary i would actually refer you
to the comments by the leader of the
council in response to the question from
councillor
denise weston relationships at the
postal to actually dim the street lights
that are now not proposing to take place
on an ongoing basis so hopefully that
will satisfy those points thank you
thank you councillor i'd said question
five council and mrs sadad
please can you now ask your question
please thank you matt
um firstly may i offer
on behalf of the full council my deepest
sympathies to sarah everard's
family as they mourn her tragic death
my question table tonight was about
street lighting
and security and i'm delighted
that the council have decided to reverse
their decision
made in the recent budget to dim
trafford street lights to save
money and i thank you for that
and my second part of the question was
regarding
street um security cameras
cctv um cameras that need to be
updated and operated by wi-fi and
councillor freeman has kindly
replied to this and with a written
response
and thank you for that thank you
counselor mr dad
do you have a supplementary question
no thank you move on to the next one
thank you councillor
question six councillor welton can your
question can we have your question
please
residents in altringham tell us that the
year-round use of loud and polluting
petrol-driven leaf blowers
by commercial grounds maintenance
companies is blighting their quiet
enjoyment of their homes and gardens
leaf blowers are also catastrophic for
our populations of insects and small
mammals
and the dust and pollen they produce add
to the discomfort and allergy of asthma
sufferers
is it time to regulate their use in
trafford
councilor i said may i ask you to
respond to another question within your
portfolio please thank you mayor
and daisy sorry and uh
councillor welcome for your question
i have submitted a response to council
welton which i've obviously i've
sent to all members on the placement
council website would councillor welton
yourself be happy if we move straight
to supplementaries or not
councillor welton yes i'd like to thank
you thank the executive member for uh
his response i do have a supplementary
question
thank you okay um
unfortunately leaf blower noise is too
often not temporary but near constant
as grounds maintenance crews move from
garden to garden
unlike the buskers in ultriam town
centre they give little public benefit
would the executive member consider
holding a consultation about the
creation of a voluntary code of conduct
on leaf blower use in trafford
councillor i said would you like to
respond
thank you mayor and council welcome for
your supplementary
i think obviously there are a couple of
uh issue points being raised there
first of all in the original response it
said that clearly
we need legislation from parliament so
we can't legislate for that
but obviously if you problems your
experience in in your own ward
i'll be coming to the point where they
where they're actually causing a lot of
issues
then obviously please do raise that uh
through
the council's uh pollution department
where we can actually look at these
problems
and actually see what how we can
actually do that so i think that'll be
the most helpful way forward at this
point
thank you mayor and council welton for
your supplementary we're happy to
discuss this of course
thank you councillor question seven is
one of two from councillor evans
councillor evans
thank you mr mayor um
residents being told and that expected
service levels for some services cannot
be met because an ongoing ransomware
into them
they have also been told that certain
documentation and drawings can no longer
be accessed because of the same issue
given that the ransomware incident was
reported in the press some three months
ago can the council tell us when the
expected service level
will return to normal here's another
question for council
that said please thank you uh now and uh
for your question councillor evans uh
obviously i did provide an extensive
written response to yourself directly
which has been placed on the council
website and sent to all members
whilst i'm happy to respond to that
directly would you be happy to move
to the straits or supplementary okay
happy to do that really
um so ransomware attacks are to be
expected they've been going on
uh for actually been quite severe over
the past 24 months or so
by large companies and public bodies
once our partner
has recovered will our audit team be
going in to conduct an
audit of their robust procedures and
have we audited
since this attack our other partners
because obviously
we are vulnerable and through other
people's actions and should it not form
part of our
performance levels that we expect from
our partners
thank you for your supplementary
question council weapons
obviously i'm not quite sure the process
uh in terms of
that we've been our partners but
obviously we're happy to look at the
concerns down there so if you'd care to
actually uh
put your quest supplemented directly to
myself i'll discuss it
directly with senior officers and we'll
get you the full written response to
that point
thank you thank you question 8
counselor your question please
i'm just finding the question
okay so a study by the research
institute for disabled commuters
in 2019 concluded that little effort has
been made to make existing
electric charging points as accessible
as possible for
disabled car users the report
highlighted practical steps can be taken
including the dropping of curbs user
experience testing with disabled
motorists
as well as improvements to design and
location choices for charging sites
so this report also rightly highlights
local authorities as a vital stakeholder
in driving this change
so please can the executive member tell
me what traffic council is doing to
ensure that electric vehicle charging
points
are made accessible to all
uh once again councillor had said would
you like to respond
thank you mayor and uh councillor both
for your question again uh provide a
written response directly to council
both who would have been placed on the
council website and central members
would yourself and council both he'd be
happy if we moved straight to the
supplementary
thank you councillor thank you very much
um thank you speaker and thank you to
the executive member for providing that
detailed answer my supplementary is can
the executive
member detail what contributions this
council has received from the
government's
on-street residential charge point
scheme
council run said central maryland county
haven't got that information directly to
hand at this moment but obviously
i will actually install that information
around that i think it was
that did feature actually in the last
report that went to executive
actually on eb charging of course there
were different
levels of uh of schemes obviously the
ones that we're doing directly
uh in trafford proposed as part of the
uh
that's gone out now uh to actually
implementation in the summer
obviously uh and there's ones that tip
transport for greater manchester
actually doing as well
in that century so and they will
actually also be implanted in schemes
so i think we'll look at try and get
that information across there and
if you care to actually uh if you'd like
to send me that directly uh
in the email following the meeting
making sure that you get that full
written responsibility
thank you for your supplementary
question council brophy
thank you question nine is the second
question from councillor evans
councilor thank you chair
um yesterday at gmca it's likely that
trafford has committed to 1.5 million
to the mayor's bus franchising scheme
giving the current budgetary pressures
could the executive member for finest
explain whether 1.5 million
will be found this question is for
councillor ross
executive member for finance and
governance thank you
thank you mayor and thank you councillor
evans for the question
in 2019-20 the council received a win
for from the racist
disposal authority of 2.7 million pounds
which was moved to reserves and 1.5
million pounds of this was earmarked to
support the council's share
of the costs of bus reform
thank you councillor evans do you have a
supplementary question
i did have something with respect to
ongoing costs but that
in the uh budget papers of 20 of
february
and that it appears that 50 1.5 million
had been spent
on covid support so that in itself
i believe at this point does not exist
and and then moving forward the varying
costs over the next five years are
between neutral
and 292 million and so so
two questions i suppose firstly it's
been spent and do we have a cotton
bottom guarantee
from gmca that they won't be calling on
us for any further contributions to the
potential costs that do range between
zero and 292 million
council ross would you like to respond
thank you matt
there was a review of reserves last year
but we've uh looked at the situation
again
and because we are in a position where
we can add to reserves at the end of
this um
this year is projected we can keep that
ring fence money and that will go
towards the um
the bus reform um obviously there's a
clear choice for
the um voters and the residents of
trafford indeed greater manchester
at this election between the status quo
and a failing bus
network not fit for purpose under the
conservatives
or a necessary change to our network
that benefits residents workers and
businesses alike
across the conibation there are far too
many people living within our borough
and across greater manchester at the
moment that have no access to decent bus
services
and this has got to change and this is
what we support with this council and
the
mayor thank you very much thank you
councillor ross
the tenth and final question is from
councillor
miss blackburn please thank you mr mayor
and residents on lost top row davey whom
have been awaiting a response from the
council since the bollards were
installed late last year
can the executive member clarify what
the legal status is
regarding the whole northern side of the
highway of lostok road
and when can residents expect an answer
um and once again can i ask councillor
to respond
thank you mayor and councillor blackman
for your question once again i've
provided council blackburn
directly with the information herself
which has been placed on the council
website and sent to all members
would counsel blackburn be and yourself
be happy if you move straight towards
supplementary
yes yes thank you councillor um
the question is is the executive member
willing to visit
and listen to the concerns of residents
on the south side of lostok road david
hume
as there are still serious safety issues
with reports of near misses and one
actual accident
whilst the resident was exiting the home
due to the installation of bollards
along the cycle track
and can he comment on why many residents
have not received responses
to emails which has caused
dissatisfaction and mistrust
following the mishandled 2020
consultation
many residents have said that whatever
their wishes are the council will ignore
them
and will counsel ads head reboot this
that's what i said would you like to
respond thank you mayor and council back
then for your supplementary
the residents who've actually sent
recent emails a letter of responses
being formally drafted to that
i've seen a uh a response earlier this
week we've asked you some
changes to that and that will be going
out to present in addition as you will
have seen
uh that there is proposals for a letter
to go out next week
which have not yet seen in that centre
obviously if residents are still having
some concerns
we did say in correspondence that went
out to residents actually uh
in the previous time around december
that that they had problems with
locations of barlow etc
so please do get in touch with us and
we'll have to come back and revisit but
that is still the case
and that's my problem i have been when i
did go out a couple of times and meet
with residents
during that period on either side of the
road and obviously i'm
obviously willing to happy to complete
residents further in that center
that isn't a problem but you can be
assured that this letter will be going
again next week and obviously residents
can get in touch and those who have
actually
sent out emails will be getting a formal
responsibility
thank you mayor and council blackman
thank you councillor assad and i'm sure
you're happy to know that that's the
last of your questions this evening
item 4 councillors requested to consider
a three-month extension to the emergency
consultation
constitutional amendments which you may
recall was agreed last year
as the crown advanced pandemic has been
declared
could i ask councillor ross the
executive member for finance and
governance
to move the report councillor ross
thank you mayor a year ago it was
envisaged that the emergency powers
would be required to safeguard the
council's democratic and decision-making
processes
at a time when we were without
legislation allowing us to hold meetings
virtually
we are now in a position where the
legislation which allowed remote voting
is about to lapse with no guarantees it
will be extended
without these emergency procedures the
constitution only provides an emergency
provision
with regard to situations which arise
between committee or executive meetings
and which require emergency action which
can only cannot reasonably
wait the next meeting we are hopeful
that an extension will not be needed for
a full year so we're just proposing that
the powers are extended for three months
although a further extension would
depend on the circumstances and in any
event would be brought back to the
council for decision
as it turns out although some emergency
executive decisions have been taken
under existing procedures
there hasn't been a need to use these
emergency provisions as agreed last year
but we'd still like to be prepared in
case the national legislation permitting
virtual release meetings
is not renewed thank you
thank you councillor ross is that
seconded please
it is secondary mr chair
thank you council weston
can i ask the count as the council in
agreement
can we can we have an eye for everybody
hi hi
hi item 5 is the pay policy statement
for 2021
22 referred from the employment
committee
and i invite councillor ross the
executive member for finance and
governance
to introduce the report to councillor
ross
thank you matt this is an annual policy
which was reviewed by members of the
employment committee on the 1st of march
2021
and has now been recommended for
approval this evening
section 6 sets out the further
information regarding the pay structure
section 12.3 provides information on
where we are in relation to the national
living wage
section 13 sets out our current pay
ratios between the highest and lowest
paid roles in the council
and section 15 provides somewhat's
explanation around the gender pay gap
as we seek to close the beam at meet the
medium pay gaps there
thank you what is that seconded
second chair thank you thank you
councillor weston um
do any members wish to speak to this
item
or to this report
no the report has been moved and
seconded can it be agreed
please hi hi
thank you item six please can councillor
wright the executive member for housing
and regeneration
introduce and move the next item
concerning the civic quarter
area action plan councilor wright
thank you mayor uh delighted to move
this report and in recognition of time
uh reserve the right to speak thank you
thank you is that seconded
thanks thank you council western do any
members wish to speak to this report
a lengthy document as as i'm sure you've
all seen
quite a lengthy document
cancelled jerome you'd like to comment
thanks chair
um i welcome this document as somebody
that sits on the
planning committee it's um good that
there's a number of documents going
forward such as the local plan
um the the plan of nine and also this
civic court plan as well
because as as planning committee members
we sometimes don't have the power to
enforce uh on things on private
developments
the way that we would want to um but i
just wanted to ask councillor right
thank you i took six please account for
the right executive member for housing
and regeneration should i carry on or
not
wait for that block to finish counseling
right let's let's carry on counselor
jerome thank you but
but i also i wanted to bring up really
some of the
developments that the the council takes
forward on on its own land and
at the moment the planning officers are
working with developers to to put
forward some very good plans around
energy efficiency
such as mhvc mechanical heat recovery
systems
heating pumps solar panels ev car share
schemes
but the the minimum energy efficiency
that they're trying to meet is is still
only five percent
above um 2013 building regulations
and i just wanted to know from
councillor right should the council
really
not be pushing for a higher minimum of
energy efficient
efficiency on it on its own on its own
council
uh developments um and and will
will that be seen in some of the plans
that are going forward over the next
couple of years thanks joe you counselor
right would you like to respond
thank you councillors jerome for you for
your question i won't pretend to be an
expert technically on
what you've just mentioned there but i'm
happy to write to you uh separately from
this meeting
uh to to guide the points that you've
raised thank you
thank you councillor wright any other
members wishing to speak
okay the report has been moved and
seconded can it be agreed
please would you like me to put this to
a vote
i think we can agree that
thanks everybody item seven i invite
council ross the executive member for
finance and governance to introduce and
move the statement
registration fee report councillor ross
thank you mayor under section 15a
commons act
2006 land owners have the ability to
deposit statements with the commons
registration authority to present
prevent the creation of town and village
greens
the council is the commons registration
authority for trafford
and has a statutory duty to deal with
these applications
the authority's first application was
received recently
the council is entitled to charge a fee
for dealing with these applications and
is registering the statements
but has not yet a fee has not yet been
set the proposed fee of 366 pounds will
cover the cost of officer time in
fulfilling these statutory duties
and is similar to fees charged by other
local authorities for this process
the reform report seeks approval of of
the statement
registration fees and approval to
delegate authority to the corporate
director for governance and community
strategy
to review and make minor adjustments to
the fee thank you
thank you councillor ross is that
seconded please
that can be chair thank you councillor
weston do any members wish to speak to
this report
councillor holden you'd like to comment
okay um no members wish to speak to that
one
the report has been moved and seconded
can it be agreed
hi hi hi
thank you item number eight and the
council is requested to agree the
provisional calendar
of council and committee meetings for
2021-22
please with the leader of the council
move this item
so moved chair thank you thank you is
that a second it please
thank you mr mayor thank you council
freedom
can he ask if the council is an
agreement
i think we're in agreement on that hi
hi hi hi
hi hi hi thanks everybody
this evening four motions have been
listed on the summons
in the order they were received yet
through the business and to give
everyone who wants an opportunity to
speak
it may be necessary to limit the time or
speeches
motion 9a the motion to convey thanks to
the trafford community
is to be moved by councillor woodson
councillor whitten please
thank you chair a year and a day
on from the first lockdown i felt it was
important that
this council puts on record it's thanks
to all those who supported the community
response to the
to the pandemic just over a year ago
council harding
and council offices brought a number of
us
together and a number of partners from
across the borough to begin to think
about how we could
uh would respond to the needs of
residents during a period when people
would be feeling vulnerable
shielding a risk of loneliness and
isolation and sure about unsure about
whether they'd be able to access things
like food
and prescriptions
within a matter of days hubs have been
stood up across the borough to respond
but it really wasn't a matter of days to
respond to the needs of residents in
different localities and we'd agreed
with cab that they'd staff
a trafford community response line since
then there have been
two and a half thousand referrals made
to the hubs and a total of 30
000 calls have been made to the cab line
hubs have been supporting over 500 uh
shielding residents and undertaken
and over 2 000 prescription pickups and
deliveries during the last
last year the response to the hubs has
been backed up by the wider community so
over that
over 500 residents volunteered to
support this effort
and this doesn't include those traffic
residents who volunteered through the
national
um rbs scheme that people will remember
from last spring at the same time this
work was complemented by mutual aid
groups with residents supporting
neighbours and checking in on vulnerable
people in their community
all the voluntary and community faith
social enterprise organizations stepped
up
existing expanding existing services or
diverting staff from resources
to directly deal with the consequences
of the of the pandemic
and in march last year um we as the
council
alongside the ccg and trafford housing
trust as major funders and commissioners
of services locally we gave immediate
reassurance to local charities and
others
that we would support the appropriate
diverting of resources and funding to
help the collective response
and to the to the pandemic the thanks
from the council tonight extends to
two larger range of organizations and
individuals and for me to list them one
by one
but it includes the the six hubs and the
wider voluntary community
faith and social enterprise sector all
of the mutual aid groups across
across trafford the social investment
team at trafford housing trust and our
other housing partners
citizens advice the ccg thrive
the traffic partnership including the
chair of the partnership roger sutton
councillors a number of whom were
directly involved in the community
response in their
in their areas and last but not least
council officers who directly delivered
support and enabled and facilitated
responses to be delivered by other
other organizations i think one thing
that marks out the the traffic response
to the pandemic to some other places is
it's just the level of partnership
working that's been involved
and it's been a genuinely collaborative
effort and this would not have been
possible without the existing commitment
to
partnership working that was in place
across a range of organizations and
stakeholders prior to the pandemic
and we reassert that commitment to
partnership working tonight
we've really seen what's possible i
think when a range of committed
individuals and organizations come
together to work towards a common goal
but all of this activity requires
capacity expertise and
resource the pandemic isn't over of
course
and the consequences will be felt for
for years to come
and the response to the needs of
residents will
shift and change over the coming months
and years as we understand the
consequences of the pandemic more
clearly
but will still require a response to
people's needs and that response will
still need to be based on strong
partnership working embedded in our in
our communities
there's sometimes a viewer expressed
that the not-for-profit sector and the
community can do more if the
if the public sector gets out of the way
and that just couldn't be
further from from the truth the public
sector as we've seen
um over the last 12 months that can work
with the volunteering community sector
to build additional support and
responses to people's needs on top of
existing core
core services and that's got to be the
way we go
but my concern sort of and this is a
concern across the country as a whole
not just not just
locally is that the financial strain
facing both non-profit organizations and
public sector organizations
which will come more clearly into focus
as we emerge from the pandemic
won't be adequately responded to by
central government
we can't equip strong partnership-based
community responses if our charities and
our local councils are starved of
resources
so word of caution there i think but as
we thank the entire
community of trafford for all that
they've done over the last
uh 12 months we've got to have an eye on
the future to ensure that we're always
able to deliver a strong community
response in this borough i mean i'm
really proud of you we've got lots of
strong
communities and localities in trafford
with their own identities
but i think what we've seen um across
the borough and that's common to the
borough
is a real sort of strong um
pride in in the in the place in the
borough real sense of
togetherness and i think it's real
opportunity as we sort of come to the
end of the municipal year
and we think and we reflect on the fact
that the pandemic's been with us for a
year now as well
that we just uh take this opportunity to
thank the community and all those
involved
in the community response over the last
last 12 months
iso move thank you chair thank you
councillor
um county council whitson is the motion
seconded uh yes chair
and you reserve the right to speak uh
cancer doctor
uh yes
um i'm aware of an amendment i've
received a note of an amendment from
councillor jerome
and i'll allow him to move cancer jerome
thank you chair um first of all
i'd like to thank the labour group and
councillor with whittam
for bringing this motion forward the
green group would also like to put on
record its thanks to the commitment
dedication of council staff
who have gone beyond the call of duty at
times in reacting to this dreadful
pandemic
this also extends to key workers
volunteers and the entire trafford
community
as this motion says who have pulled
together in such
difficult times i'm pleased that this
administration is reaffirming its
position of partnership working
with the clear aim of putting the best
outcomes for residents first
so thank you it's also been a pleasure
to see so many councillors across the
political
spectrum getting out and helping in that
community effort too
and to see councillor welton and coggins
on their cargo bikes supporting that
effort
as this motion says the pandemic is not
over
but maybe with the vaccination program
we are seeing a time
when restrictions may be eased the
lockdown has brought people together
in the form of community spirit but at
the same time it's kept so many people
apart
as a green group we felt that
encouraging people to apply to close
their streets for the purposes of
reconnecting
breaking down isolation and harnessing
the tremendous community spirit
during this lockdown would be a good
thing this
this apologies this could be a street
party
or a play street the council does have
real financial constraints so we're
asking for this to be considered
for the council to look at some of the
costs the tro
applications liability insurance
administration fees
and to see some of these uh to see if
some of these can be waived
capped or taken on by the council for a
period
but also to consider how this could be
administered
we commend the council for running a
playing out or play street pilot scheme
in 2019
we would now like to see this stepped up
again we've campaigned for this as a
party for some time
and would love to see a rollout in
altringham we know closing
rose to traffic and letting kids play
improves health
build stronger communities and this red
resident-led
action would continue the positive
community spirit shown by so many in the
lockdown
it's sustainable relatively cheap and it
delivers fun
and enjoyment this is something the
council could give to communities
across the borough something
that would strengthen them further so i
implore councillors from all parties to
support this motion
and this amendment thank you chair
thank you councillor jerome um is the
amendment seconded
it is thank you uh thank you mayor
okay um i've got a list of speakers but
i'm conscious though
we want people to be speaking to the
amendment rather the main motion
um so councilor brophy you were first on
my list
would you like to speak to the amendment
please
oh i'm going to be speaking to the
amendment but i'll also be making points
that support the motion as well
okay so this motion is about our
community thank you
our local authority played a vital and
essential role on behalf of the liberal
democrat group
i'd especially like to thank everybody
our volunteers in particular
our communities rose to this challenge
for example during the first lockdown
residence in templeley set up the
timpani support group facebook group
it's got over 1800 followers its members
have gone above
and beyond to help vulnerable residents
and along with many colleagues
i volunteered for one of our hubs and
played an active role
in the ultrim hub in our area it's
fitting
that we record our thanks for the
tremendous community spirit in temple
and across trafford on behalf of global
democrats we are supporting the motion
but we're also supporting the green
amendment because we think the green
amendment
it will help make our streets safer
it'll help make them
healthier and it will be more
environmentally friendly and it'd be
great
if there's a legacy for the covid times
that we had this
in place to make the things in the
motion there in the amendment for
playing out
and looking at making our the play
streets pilot scheme work
hopefully across all of the borough it
will be a great legacy to have
and we are supporting the motion and the
amendment thank you mayor
very much councillor harding
thank you mayor um i'm i want to speak
to the
uh original motion that um counsellor
whitton had brought but i'm just going
to
make reference to the amendment really
and to say
that i am quite disappointed with the
amendment that has
been brought because it's not really in
the spirit of the motion that was put
forward
this evening um the spirit of the motion
this evening was a genuine and heartfelt
thank you to our community for the way
that they have stepped up and responded
to this
pandemic and really last night as i
stood on my doorstep and lit
my candle and i commemorated the day of
reflection
my immediate thoughts were that i can't
actually believe it has been a year and
i don't think that any of us in this
chamber
has not been touched and affected by
this pandemic
we all know loss we all know grief um we
all know sadness and we all know
loneliness and not being able to see
our loved ones and my mind turned back
to that very day that counselor whittam
had
referred to really it was incredible to
see the willingness
of all of those people in that room that
um
were step stepping up really and the
letters that were going through
doors from neighbours the whatsapp
groups that were set up with genuine
acts of kindness
and that was what we saw it was the
spirit of our community and that's why i
feel so passionately about
the motion that was brought because that
was about the spirit of our community
it's not about playing politics which is
what i feel the green motion is
absolutely doing
we are here to say thank you to those
people that stepped
up so we saw the spirit of a can-do
attitude
um bold and visionary that in 10 years
as a councillor we've broken down those
barriers that have caused me intense
frustration
over those years and those six community
hubs were then
set up and one thing i do know is that
we cannot
go back we cannot go back to those days
the word community has to be front and
center
of all of the strategies policies and
solutions that we seek to deliver
really and as we work to recover i just
want to say that this kindness is
definitely ongoing
i was very privileged to hold an event
with over a hundred trafford women for
international women's day
some amazing stories of kindness
commitment and a genuine love of all
they do
for their community and i see it at the
vaccine clinics that take place on a
weekly basis
people helping people stepping up to
help our gps and residents
so from the bottom of my heart a genuine
heartfelt thank you
to all of the incredible community
groups the faith groups the hubs and
volunteers
that have gone the extra mile over this
pandemic trafford has many great
assets but let me say that its people
and communities are one of the greatest
thank you thank you councillor harding
councillor shelly proctor
thank you chair i want to make a brief
comment
and it's to the original emotion
i'd like to thank the people involved in
two particular facebook groups
m41s and m41s be kind
who together raised money
to enable me to manage a team
of 14 people making scrubs during
lockdown one
when the government couldn't supply
scrubs to our precious
nhs i was so proud of the people
involved
in this project and we made scrubs for
almost all the hospitals in greater
manchester and beyond
so thank you to m41 scrubs
for the amazing dedication you showed
and thank you to the two facebook groups
for funding that sadly desperately
necessary work
thank you thank you councillor proctor
councillor evans
thank you chair and i'd just like to i
can't really speak to the amendment
it doesn't it doesn't sit badly but it
doesn't say it seems it just
a position to the spirit as capital
harding said so i'd like to echo
um councillor wittens and councillor
harding sentiment towards this
and there are far too many organizations
to mention
i've experienced the hubs i've done some
work in the hubs
and they have been superb and the the
comments from across the borough
that they delivered what they were
supposed to deliver which were just
great
and we missed out the new volunteers at
the vaccine centers
absolutely essential but there are
people doing eight nine
ten hour shifts just guiding cars but
essential work and it's absolutely
precious to us
and then finally and the the schools to
stay open throughout
to school the children of our key
workers
so i think it's a great motion and that
the group as a whole
will be supported thank you
thank you councillor evans uh councillor
weston please
thanks chair much in the same vein as
council harding councillor evans
really i i just think that this um this
has been slightly
misjudged it's an attempt to um
harness policy change through the
mechanism of emotion thanking
our community and and i i just think
it's slightly wide of the mark in that
regard i appreciate
that that we are here to elicit change
but in in my view i think it i think
it's just the wrong
tact to have taken on this and the labor
group won't be supporting
the amendment i do um just need to
apologize to councillor jerome because i
can't see the vu member just before the
meeting unfortunately i was in
um meetings until until directly prior
to the meeting
um or i would have let him know that
that's where we were on this i i think
we have to be very very careful about
about what we
um what what we cross over and
intertwine um with this i think it's
extremely important that we have
something
so straightforward as a thank you so um
all-encompassing to pull out all of the
various volunteers and community
organizations that have been highlighted
by the speakers so far but there
is um another group that i do just wish
to highlight who are mentioned in the
motion but
um haven't come out so strongly in the
speakers so far
not that they don't recognize their
achievements but that i do think that we
we have to um recognize them
particularly
as we enter um what what is widely known
as the politicians silly season and
things may be said that
that might be regrettable in this regard
i just want to thank our staff
because in addition to the
thousands of volunteers who have been
magnificent all of the community
organizations that have been superb
our staff have led this response from
the front and that it starts with the
chief executive saratoga
and it works through to every single
person
in this organization doing things that
one year ago
they could not have imagined would be
part of their daily duties and routine
they have shown us what public service
means and they have supported
thousands of people in trafford who for
various different reasons
may have suffered loss may have been
made unemployed may have been shielding
or isolating
the council has either directly
intervened through our fantastic staff
or have used our convening powers and
our partnership role to ensure that
others could do so
and i don't think that we can ever thank
them in a chair so i do just want to
place that
on the record whilst saying that that
unfortunately
um whilst we will be bringing forward
work on play streets in the very near
future
i don't think that we can accept this
amendment this evening and
we will be voting against and supporting
the substantive motion thanks chad
thank you councillor rad said you'd like
to comment
thank you uh yes sir and the amendment
obviously uh
this uh timely following on the back of
councillor western's comments uh
i have uh i did set up the uh the group
actually looking at play streets and uh
i think i'd like to
crack one point that was making
obviously there was a trial uh scheme
that was out there
but we did seek to extend that and we
did actually uh one like myself but
officers did actually uh
advertise it among community groups and
everything across the border
uh in in 19 and and
there was two responses back from the
moving tour groups who wanted to proceed
in that sense that we did work with
those groups to look at the problems and
issues
and and obviously uh unfortunately
because of the pandemic they did not
proceed
in that sense it's obviously we
obviously really want to actually
progress these schemes obviously this is
not the right motion to do that because
this is actually thanking
everybody involved with the pandemic
that's what's left her
counselors know that actually that work
wasn't going it simply wasn't forgotten
and then the round would use er so with
that as council western indicated
that that will the post pandemic will be
coming out and as soon as it's uh
government allows that i just would like
to get these schemes up and running
again
in that center and if there are ones
that come forward we look at that we'll
obviously have to
have report that indicates how that can
actually happen but i think just had my
thanks to everybody
that's actually been involved with the
pandemic it's been uh i think it's
something
that anybody alive today has really
experienced this
and i think it's it's everyone's giving
away we couldn't think
uh would have happened just a year ago
so to include my thanksgiving obviously
thank you rather thank you councillor
said
councillor welton please
thank you chair um i will uh add my
voice to
all those who will be thanking um
everybody
who's responded to the pandemic today
and
you know i was out delivering on my
cargo bike on
a tf transport for greater manchester
cargo bike that we've been lent in
altering him
and i was delivering for the altering
aid hub today and it's fantastic
to just turn up with a bike with
everything absolutely ready to go
um you know to to to take to people food
bank recipients to
isolating people to people who need to
receive medicine
and i'm amazed every time i go how
efficient
and and how hard working everybody is
there
and as a member of the public protect
protection um committee i want to pay
tribute
also to our taxi drivers and our mini
cab drivers and all our also our bus
drivers who have often been
at the um you know they're serving in
one of the highest risk um categories of
of employment um but um just
in regards to the amendment i i'm i
think it's a shame that it's been
regarded as political because i think
making it easier for our communities to
celebrate
and play together would be an
appropriate way to thank them
for everything that has been done all
the sacrifices that people have made
during the pandemic and i
would very much hope that members will
support the amendment um
in that vein thank you very much thank
you councillor wilson
councillor anderson please thank you
very much mr smyrn
um i just wanted to um reflect earlier i
suppose um just briefly on
um 13 years in trafford and
to to speak on this motion actually it's
quite it's quite fitting
because what it does is epitomizes um
the strengths that is the collections of
communities that you see in chocolate
we've always argued previously that
traffic traffic itself is not
is not a place it is a collection of
communities
that come together to be able to and you
know to really support each other we've
seen that over the last
uh yeah and and my plea really to to
to fellow members as you sort of take
the borough into the future is the
the strength and the um
the learnings of the last 12 months as
we hope
the health aspect of this pandemic draws
to us
to a conclusion and that that those
strengths also feed through into the
future about the economic well-being of
our communities
as we as we progress and that same
enthusiasm and that's the same concern
uh and that same uh appreciation of
looking out for each other
uh continues to form part of chocolate's
response and certainly one and
just one final thing to say really i
suppose is that um it's just to reflect
and the contribution and i know and
colleagues at trafford housing trust and
are hugely
um appreciative of the support the
council um has put in place and that
partnership working
um that has always been what we all
wanted to see has actually really
coalesced around the response that is
that
uh that was that the pandemic required
and that hopefully that the brewer can
sustain that into the future
um and that being well then traffic can
continue to be
a place where we all look out for each
other and we see this type of response
into the future as well so huge um
congratulations and
and fully supporting motion to say thank
you to all of our communities for all
they've done thank you very much
thank you councillor i've got no other
speakers
um councillor whitsum has the right to
reply councillor whitson
thanks chair i mean yeah in respect of
the
uh amendments would would just agree
with what some
councillor western and others have said
that it's not
in in the spirit and it's not in keeping
with the spirit of the motion
and tonight you know it looks to to
um tack on a quite specific issue
onto a motion that's um that's broader
and
bigger than that specific issue so
um as councilor weston has said
the the labour group won't be supporting
the amendment
to the motion when we go to that vote
chair
thank you um i'm going to put that to
the vote now
that's the amendment
and you can see the box in front of you
i hope you can all
[Music]
vote
all right
okay everybody so the amendment has been
lost the amendment has been lost
um do any members wish to speak to the
main motion
we've had a good discussion but i want
to give you opportunity to speak
to the main motion anybody like to speak
no okay
dr carr would you like to speak
um thank you chair i'd i'm incredibly
proud and honored to second this motion
i started the pandemic on a drug that
meant i was a clinically extremely
vulnerable and had to fully shield
i have therefore experienced first-hand
the timely and impressive response
to support shielding residents
coordinated by the council
the support on offer was incredibly
reassuring at a very worrying
and uncertain time i'd like to echo my
thanks
to all the volunteers and council
officers who helped to coordinate this
response
which has made such a huge difference to
residents at risk
who may have felt isolated and
frightened and which we should be
rightly proud of
fortunately after coming off that
medication i returned to work in acute
medicine
and looked after patients were covered
many of them trafford residents
i've seen the incredible devastation and
heartache that this disease has caused
no resident in trafford has been
unaffected by this
despite personal hardship bereavement
financial worries and ill health so many
residents have continued to volunteer
and continue to work as key workers as
well as residents who have done that bit
extra to help neighbours and friends
i'd also like to extend my particular
thanks to our social workers
our social workers are sometimes our
forgotten key workers
and they have had to work in incredibly
challenging circumstances over this past
year with increasing caseloads
and have done an outstanding job
i'll finish with a final heartfelt
thanks to all our key workers
charitable organizations volunteers
council officers and residents
who have given so much and continue to
do so
thanks chair thank you councillor dr
carr
councillor whitam you do have the right
to reply um
i'm not sure you want to exercise that
but thanks actually no i'll just be
really really quick and interested
at the time you threw me before when you
brought me back in at that point some
stuff
so yeah thanks ted so yeah i mean
did you iterate really just in
particular thanks to
the council staff and i think there's
there's two things to that because what
what council western said
in terms of that redeployment of the
council staff and directly supporting
people
but also i've seen a very close hand
over the last 12
months the way in which council officers
have facilitated and enabled other
organizations community groups and
others across the borough
to support people it's been really been
that breaking down of barriers
between the public sector and the
voluntary community sector in the
borough that we've really seen over the
last 12 months it's made
such a difference and i think to echo
just to finish to echo
and what councilor and steam councillor
harding said
he's trying to capture that spirit and
maintain it as we hopefully move past
and beyond
the pandemic so we can continue to work
in that
genuine spirit of sort of collaboration
where we're not putting enough barriers
um in front of each other but we're
actually supporting um
each other to kind of work effectively
and come together to
address challenges and solve problems so
really pleased with the contributions or
most the contributions we've had tonight
and i just wanted to thank members
and for understanding the sort of spirit
in which this motion was brought
brought tonight and i think it's been
really positive and it to me it feels
like a good
way to mark the end of the municipal
year
thanks jeff absolutely thank you
councillor whitson i'll now put the
substantive motion to the vote
that motion has been agreed
second motion this evening regarding a
commitment to social
and economic justice is to be moved by
council london
council london please thank you chair
in 2019 the international monetary fund
reported the uk
was the sixth richest country in the
world but over the last
40 years we've witnessed the
concentration of income and wealth
amongst the very richest in our society
with the very poorest getting still
poorer
no wonder then that the uk is at the top
of the oecd countries for income
inequality second only to the usa
as the marmot review and the council's
first ever poverty strategy has shown
the impact of these inequalities looms
large in the economically divided
borough
we all call home life expectancy in
trafford varies by eight
years depending on where you live in the
borough
just short of twelve thousand children
live in poverty in trafford
the majority of these children are
concentrated in wards like clifford
and buckler saint martins well over
double the amount found in some wards
in the south end of the borough
south trafford food bank operating in
one of the richest parts of greater
manchester
has i am ashamed to report
seen a 209 increase
in the number of users over the last
seven years
this motion highlights some of the
actions that have been urgently needed
for
many years now in order for this country
to recover from the financial crisis
of 2008 and the economic fallout of the
pandemic
chair i put this motion to the council
tonight in the hope that we might shine
a light on
and for the prime minister to focus on
economic and social justice for
all and not just a few at the top of the
economic hierarchy
only yesterday the british academy
warned us
all that failure to understand the scale
of the challenge ahead
and deliver the kind of changes outlined
in this motion
would result in a rapid slide towards
poorer
societal health more extreme patterns of
inequality
and fragmenting national unity
this government may be happy to leave
that sorry picture to the next
generation
but the trafford labor group will do
everything in our power
to mitigate this government's neglect of
the majority
of trafford's citizens thank you chair
thank you council london is the motion
seconded
uh yes mayor i'd like to second it but i
will uh reserve the right thank you
thank you councillor slater um members
wishing to speak i've already got a list
of people so do
let me know in the chat facility if
you'd like to speak first speakers
councillor german councillor german
thank you chair yeah so
obviously after 11 years of austerity
the economy is already
behind the curve investment is urgently
needed in almost every area
of public life the nhs was woefully
under resourced when the pandemic hit
and has performed miracles to achieve
the outcome the outcomes in the
circumstances and
kept everybody as safe as possible
but the downside of this is the growing
backlog
of critical care in in other areas
authorities have been at the front line
of helping communities through the
pandemic
and though and although they've been
given significant sums of
public money by the government this has
still left a huge
gap in resources
the education divide has widened due to
the pandemic
and as the schools were not staved to
fully to fully
to fully open and this must be addressed
as a matter of priority
many families have been facing hardship
and permanent job with permanent jobs
lost and businesses gone to the wall
obviously already the the cost of the
cup has cost the country huge sums of
money
and and also globally
but a year ago the government correctly
stated that it cost it cost whatever it
costs
so it's like coming out of a major world
war
but we just don't have a choice to put
this right
but as we build back we we need to
strive to eradicate
eradicate inequalities and social
injustice
we need a national investment bank for
manufacturing
the green economy decent houses
and safer streets to name but a few
areas
the prime minister is always pushing the
leveling up agenda
so in theory this is something that we
should all support
thank you chair
thank you that's the german i'm going to
bring in councillor corgines now because
um
i believe she's had a hand up for a time
and uh failed to spot us so
councillor coggins you'd like to comment
thank you chair i can i briefly thank uh
all those thanked in the in the previous
uh motion and also the cancer standing
down and especially those who have
given long years of service um i do
agree with the wording of the motion and
the green group will be voting to
support the motion tonight
um however i do think there's
insufficient focus on the biggest social
justice issue that we are facing
we all know that the impacts of the
climate crisis are felt
disproportionately by the poorest in our
society
by women and by those in the global
sites and yet we know that they are not
the people responsible for causing the
problem
in fact there's just 100 companies are
responsible for
71 of all the carbon emissions that we
have made which is really a remarkable
record
and and of course many of those
companies um are the ones that
um trafford and other greater manchester
um
boroughs have invested one billion
pounds
of our pension funds in in fact many of
the companies are very near the top of
that list
these are the most destructive companies
in history and are primarily labor run
councils across greater manchester
really really need to
to get this in in order and can i also
respectfully ask
my labor colleagues and friends to
reflect also on their party's views on
electoral reform
uh in view of the commitment to social
justice and to constructive cross-party
working that we see
in this in this motion um a fundamental
tenet of any just society has to be that
every vote counts
and the votes of residents across the
country are
all of roughly equal value however the
broken
first pass supposed system supported by
both labor and the conservative party
uh actually increases the inequality in
our society and bizarrely disadvantages
the labour party
and last at the last general election
the conservative party won only 44
of the vote but as they got 56
of the seats they've been able to
implement their destructive and
devastating policies
so i would respectfully ask our labour
colleagues to continue to do their best
to ensure
that the policies and the actions of
their own party live up to the values
that we all share
thank you thank you thank you councillor
coggins councillor brophy
thank you mayor so this motion's about a
commitment to social and economic
justice
and we will be supporting this motion so
just to point out about the beverage
report mentioned in the
motion a liberal idea introduced by
labour government
this led to the creation of the modern
welfare state
which is so really made the biggest
difference to
addressing inequality and we have the
nhs
in our country which is just something
that
really helped with the pandemic and the
roll out of the vaccine that we've seen
but the impacts have covered has led to
the need for a new beverage invitation
to
to change things for current generations
because we know
that the first five years of a child's
life make the biggest difference
to their long-term health and prospects
in life
and we still do not know the full
long-term impact that coronavirus and
lockdown has had on our children's
mental health
there's been some research in the lancet
that shows that children in households
that are struggling to meet bill
payments
are twice as likely to have high
probable mental health issues
this is deeply concerning when we
consider the rising level of
unemployment
and loss of earnings that many families
face in the light of covid19
there is an objective set out in the
motion to develop healthy and
sustainable places and communities
this is a considerable challenge which
our borough must deal with
runaway house prices present the biggest
threat to social mobility in our
community
they increase inequality those who are
not forced into the wild west of private
rented sector
are staying at home well into their 30s
or often choosing to leave trafford
altogether
since 2012 traffic house prices have
been surging
by 2018 the affordability ratio in
trafford
was 9.4 ahead of the english average
of eight and well ahead of the greater
manchester score of 6.3
so in summarising on behalf of the
liberal democrat group i would like to
urge all
councillors to support this motion
especially
as the inequalities of our own borrower
of trafford so urgently
need to be addressed thank you mayor
thank you
councillor heinz please thank you
um mayor um so i'd just like to say in
response to
councillor coggins comments um that the
uh the labour group absolutely lived by
the values in
um this motion um and i think our
poverty strategy and the council's
corporate
equality strategy are absolutely
testament to that
and the pandemic has brought existing
inequalities
into sharp focus and for many has
exacerbated them
disadvantaged and vulnerable adults and
have disproportionately become seriously
ill
or died from cohered which has often
been related to socioeconomic
circumstances
and existing wider causes of health
inequality
and the most vulnerable children and
young people have disproportionately
struggled to access education and home
learning potentially
further impacting their life chances as
people start to turn towards
the easing of lockdown restrictions and
the ending of furlough
there are growing fears of the
sustainability of many businesses
across a number of sectors and the
impact
this will have on the labor market the
evidence
is overwhelming that unless a government
takes decisive action
young people are always the most
disadvantaged
and stand to become disenfranchised by
an
unstable labour market and the most
vulnerable young people will be the
worst impacted
are fully supportive of the labor motion
it's time to take an ambitious and
creative approach
to addressing inequality we know that
the financial cost to the public purse
of covid
is massive but it's essential that the
government
don't dial back from this now the way
through this
is by creating a strong and inclusive
economy
that provides opportunity for all into
the future
through investment in early years and
education
in infrastructure and linking people
with inclusive growth
and good job creation thank you mayor
thank you councillor hines councillor
hartley please
uh thank you mayor the the beverage
report identified
five giants to to tackle want
disease ignorance squalor and idleness
we're obviously tackling a disease now
in the form of the pandemic
but when william beveridge and his
colleagues penned these words in 1942
i'm sure they could never imagined that
we would still see want
ignorance and squalor in our society in
2021
don't be fooled by the government's
smoke screen the increasing levels of
inequality are down to the pandemic
and like so much in the government
response to the pandemic there's nothing
that they can do about it
this pandemic has not affected everyone
equally
it has affected the most those least
able to deal with the consequences
it has laid barely inequalities that
existed before the pandemic
and which were exacerbated by 10 years
of tour austerity
i know that i think most members in the
chamber know that
and professor sir michael marmot knew
that when he published his 10-year
review
of his original recommendations
published in february 2020 so before
the pandemic and it's worth reflecting
on some of those
uh findings that that he made which
focused particularly on
health inequalities among women in the
most deprived 10
of areas life expectancy fell fell
between 2010 and 2016 18.
there are regional differences in life
expectancy particularly amongst people
living in most deprived areas and we see
that here in trafford as
council london mentioned the difference
of eight years in life expectancy
between the north and south of the
borough here in trafford mortality rates
have increased
increased for people aged 45 to 49 over
the last 10 years
that's the age bracket that i've fallen
to know but i but i don't think of
myself as approaching mortality
it's likely that social and economic
conditions have undermined health
at these ages that was a finding which
marmot made
the amount of time that people spend in
poor health has increased across england
since
2010 again we see that in trafford with
residents living in the north of the
borough
suffering around 10 years more poor
health than those
in the more affluent south large funding
cuts that we've seen
have affected the social determinants of
health across the whole of england
and they've also affected the capacity
of local services
to respond to those challenges health
inequalities are increasing
for almost all of the recommendations
made in the original marmot review
marmot found that the country has been
moving in the wrong direction
over the last 10 years in particular
lives for people at the bottom
have been made more difficult there's a
large body of evidence which shows that
countries with higher levels of
inequality
suffer from higher levels of crime lower
levels of trust
and lower levels of happiness a more
equal society
provides better results for everyone
rich and poor
but this rotten government this morally
bankrupt government shows no ability
and no inclination to address the plague
of inequality which has swept across our
country
and across our borough over the last 10
years so i urge members to support this
motion
thank you
thank you councillor hartley councillor
harding please
thank you mayor i think for me the one
thing that struck me throughout this
pandemic was seeing
photographs that came out of burnley
where we literally had
people cueing and starving
that for me was just absolutely
heartbreaking and i cannot believe
that in this day and age that that we
are seeing those sites
the previous motion attracted
cross-party support
speakers spoke with passion and
gratitude about
and for our communities i expect the
same for this motion
really councilor anthony spoke of
economic equality and that he hopes that
it attracts the same
spotlight as health inequalities and
he's absolutely right
i would hope that that happens too i sit
here as a counsellor of 10 years
repeating the same lines of years of
life lost
for those people that live in our most
deprived wards
across trafford repeating those same
lines 10 years down the line but in fact
as counselor london has referenced in
his original motion
it's actually worsened and it is
shameful that michael marmot's work
is now highlighting just how how the gap
has widened
around health inequalities
i would just like to say that health
scrutiny is a cross-party
working group and committee and each and
every member of that committee who sits
on that group knows
about the crisis across social care
the crisis across cancer care and young
people's mental health
and those are three critical things that
have borne
the burden of this pandemic
with that in mind i would that i see no
reason why all members cannot support
this motion
we have worked together in a cross-party
way and i have to say
if not now when when will we ever truly
address
the shame of health inequalities thank
you
thank you councillor harding councillor
evans please
thank you chair who can object to social
and economic justice
but this motion doesn't do that there
are
portions of this motion that one could
support
but there are major sections of it that
this conservative group just
simply cannot support so we i even
attempted amending it but it's just
too rambling so we won't be supporting
this motion
but i would like to say the uk
government has delivered one of the most
comprehensive
economic responses in the world to
protect jobs and livelihoods through the
coronavirus pandemic
over this year and into next they will
be providing over 407 billion
pounds worth of support for families
jobs and businesses
more than almost any other country in
the world
which includes furlough grant
self-employed
bounce-back loans i could go on and on
but i'm sure you don't want to hear it
and so i'll i'll
relieve you of that now unfortunately we
won't be supporting this motion there
are parts of it that are just
unsupportable thank you thank you
councillor evans councillor weston
please
thank you chair it is disappointing but
perhaps not entirely surprising to her
that the conservative group won't be
supporting
this motion it might perhaps have been
useful to understand
um what it is that the conservatives
grew conservative group disagree with in
this motion actually to attempt to
understand why they don't wish to commit
to
social and economic justice i think it's
um particularly unsavory to have them
say
that they won't support it without
giving the reasons why and i can't at
the moment
see any of the conservative speakers
wishing to contribute
i do think that is that is deeply
regrettable and residents will be
um shocked but i will just comment on on
a couple of the other
contributions if that's okay chair
because councillor brophy's absolutely
correct when she talks about
the beverage um report being a liberal
idea that it took a labor government to
introduce
sadly austerity was a conservative idea
and it took the liberal democrats
to introduce that but such is such as
life
unfortunately um councillor hartley
mentioned the five tenets of the
beverage report want disease ignorance
squalor
and idleness but in policy terms chair
what we're effectively talking about is
health welfare
education housing and justice and if we
look at what has unfolded in this
country over the past
11 years chair in those areas it is a
sorry sorry
tale on health we have a crisis of
funding in social care that is getting
worse not better
an nhs that has been consistently
underfunded
where we have a shortage as we have seen
over the past year of critical care beds
indeed one of the lowest
numbers of these per capita in europe we
have
um a welfare system where people have
had their benefits cuts are facing
sanctions
universal credit is in disarray and
pension of poverty on the rise in
education we have seen countless
issues and the funding in particular of
early years
decimated through the closure of shore
start centers
based on housing of course we have a
housing crisis something which we in
this chamber chair
tend to um all agree on although we have
very different
ideas of the actions that are actually
required to physically do something
about it but in particular
chair in the area of justice we've seen
in many ways
the most understated and least talked
about but in many ways most serious
of um of impacts and that is in access
to justice because the cuts to legal aid
that we have seen since 2010
are not only sharp a sharp stark rather
excuse me chair and shocking but they
also point
to a government that has no regard for
people's ability to protect themselves
in those other spheres
because obviously if you are reliant on
the benefit
system to survive you will need access
to legal aid to fight
that system if you are impoverished you
will need legal aid
to fight for justice if you are denied
access to health care or education
you will need legal aid to fight that
injustice and that is why this motion is
so
important and that is why chair i have
to say yet again
whilst i welcome the fact that the green
group are supporting this motion tonight
i find myself disappointed
by them yet again acting in a tangential
way
that brings in issues that are not
relevant to this motion and we have play
streets
on the first motion and here we are
chair with
comments about electoral reform in a
motion that seeks to support
the poorest in society and close the
inequalities gap and i have to say to
councillor coggins
the last time that we had a referendum
on electoral reform in this country it
was supported by the leader of the
labour party
and the fact of the matter is that
actually i think the green group are
better than this
shoehorning in their niche issues we
know
that they are only concerned with a very
very narrow
range of interests but i have become a
custom chair to them engaging with
broader debates about inequalities
and economic and social justice in a
constructive way
rather than shoehorning in something as
frankly
um bizarre to the debate as electoral
reform that is an important issue
in and of itself but i failed to see its
relevance when considering
issues as important as this so i do find
that disappointing chair but overall
as i said we have seen a collapse
really in the support laid out through
the actions of the labour government of
1945
building on the ideas initially set out
in the beverage report and that is why
this motion is so important thank you
john
thank you councillor weston um
councillor shelly proctor
thank you chair at the beginning of the
pandemic
as people went into hospital and then
people
started to die we heard on the news on
the radio
in the press oh they had underlying
conditions
and that continued to be a theme people
with underlying conditions
seem to be less worth than the people
without
underlying conditions and when we look
at the number
the percentage of deaths 65 percent
of the people who've died from covered
19 in the uk
are disabled people with underlying
conditions
disabled people on the whole
live in poverty so much more
than the rest of the community
and yesterday and today letters have
gone out
from dwp to disabled people up and down
the country
to tell them of their increase in their
personal independence payments
is the massive increase of 75 p
a week for the people on the higher rate
of for both care and mobility
75 p that's less than 0.5
percent of the total amount they receive
to live on this government is a disgrace
we have got people starving to death in
this country disabled people dying
because they couldn't afford to turn on
the electricity
to put keep the fridge going so that
their initially
insulin doses stayed safe this
government
is systematically killing disabled
people
and it keeps on doing it it's no
wonder that so many disabled people have
died
when you get an increase of 75 p
a week does that even buy some milk
no does that even buy a loaf of bread no
this government should be ashamed of it
and i am proud
of this council and the stand we take on
poverty
thank you chair
thank you councillor shelly proctor um
councillor book please
thank you chair uh i just want to come
in on this and
say that i mean the the ideal vision of
fully energy efficient and carbon
neutral living wage
employment across the country paying
enough taxes to fund all
the societal needs has yet to be
achieved by any one country or block in
the world
under any political system or party uh
additionally the pandemic has greatly
worsened the economic
distress and the full impact has yet to
be heard felt
enormous levels of national debt will
have to be taken on
and successive generations will have to
take the burden
this amendment goes somewhere in
reviving the country in the best way
possible
to tackle this unprecedented situation
and support the needs
the health and welfare of all vulnerable
and disabled people
and those who need it so i would urge
people
members to support the amendment thank
you chair
um okay we're gonna go to the final
speaker
this evening on this and council london
has the right to reply but councillor
welton
councillor wilson thank you very much um
uh mayor um i
support everything that's in this uh
in this motion but i am gobsmacked by
councillor weston saying that electoral
reform is a niche
issue where nearly 200 constituency
labor parties have already called for it
the fact that it that the fact is that
if the labour party if the labour party
had reformed the electoral system
when it had the chance we wouldn't have
had successive tory governments
pursuing their austerity agenda so
really a very strange comment from him
thank you councillor wilson and council
london you have the right to reply
council london
do i need to second it man apologies
council slater do you want to uh use
your right to speak yeah
of course you must do that please thank
you thank you
and i just like to thank everybody who
spoke in favor of the motion
but i am not surprised at all that the
conservative group have decided
that they will um abstain or perhaps
vote against
the motion so um against this backdrop
of ten years of austerity
this pandemic has highlighted the
inequality of this country
and it has been presided over by this
tory government
and with the with and originally with
the lib dem
um coalition local services in
particular have been cut to the bone as
council budgets have been slashed year
on year
sooner or later these those at the top
of government over the last 10 years
need to accept that services that have
been that
have been cut to dangerous levels and
the real impact
on the poorest families in society is so
prevalent
now professor chris whittie the chief
medical officer for england warned this
week
that the government needs to take
seriously the impact of poverty on
health
poverty is a public health issue
we need as this motion says a national
cross-party con
committee to tackling the crisis of
inequality in this country
a crisis that has deepened as a result
of the pandemic
we need to tackle inequality in
education with more equitable funding to
drive up attainment in all areas
we need to create good jobs with fair
employment building on the excellent
work or carry
already carried out in greater
manchester with a good employment
charter
and we need to end precarious employment
and zero hours contracts
we need a real living wage and a
complete overhaul of universal credit
so that families have enough to live on
and they have can live healthy lives
we need to acknowledge that the levels
of inequality we have we are seeing now
are unsustainable and we need people who
are
at the top of political um agenda arena
to reverse some of the horrific levels
of inequality across this country
we need this cross-party review that
this motion calls for
so we can tackle inequality poverty and
the health crisis that has been caused
i fully support the motion and i hope
that the majority in this
chamber can also support this motion i
second this motion thank you
thank you council slater councillor
london and uh
just just to make you aware council
london we are running late and
appreciate your help
in that matter if you can thank you very
much
yeah thank you chair i'd like to thank
all councillors contributions this
evening and i particularly like to
uh thank the uh the greens and the
liberal democrats for their support
for the motion um we could have spent
a lot longer writing a much bigger
motion but of course we had to um
we had to cut it off at some point what
i
would say regarding the contributions
from the conservative members is what a
surprise
the basic problem here is what divides
the majority in this chamber from
the now minority the conservatives
is the majority want to see genuinely
well-being and good quality lives for
for all our residents
it seems to me that the the tory
mentality
and ideology uh best summed up actually
by the prime minister himself when he
was addressing his
uh black bench mps only yesterday
and he used the famous phrase greed is
good uh mr chair greed is good
and that sums up really the tour of
philosophy
that the individual must always
always come first and that the
individual that goes on to succeed
must always always take most even if
that means
the rest of the society falls to the
wayside even though that
seems we see a 209 increase
in south trafford's food bank users
and all the other outrageous indicators
that various members have elaborated on
tonight
this is the fundamental difference
between the majority and the minority in
this chamber
and this is why the tories lost control
of the council in 2018. so thank you for
the majority support and i look forward
to seeing this
um passed with that majority thank you
chair
thank you council london i will now put
the motion to the vote
the motion is carried the motion is
carried
the third motion regarding the gmb
domestic abuse charter
is to be moved by the leader of the
councillor council andrew weston please
thanks chairman at the outset of moving
this motion i will just um
reiterate my written declaration of
interest that i am a member of the gmb
um i don't think that i technically need
to because it is declared but just
for transparency so that members are
aware
but that said this should be a fairly um
straightforward motion we had a
considerably lengthy
and important debate on domestic
violence last year so we i don't think
we need to
um spend much time dealing with this but
i view it as a practical
intervention on the issue of domestic
abuse that i hope will be
welcomed by all members there's nothing
controversial
um in this in this charter and i hope
all members will be able to support it
but in the interests of time chair i
will stop there thank you
thank you councillor weston for your
help with that um before i move to the
secondary do any members wish to declare
an interest in this item
council law thank you
and i would like to declare an interest
in that
uh i'm a trustee of trafford domestic
abuse services
thank you
obviously not giving you the opportunity
to speak earlier counselor lloyd
councillor thomas you'd like to speak
thank you matt it's just to register
that i'm also a member of the gmb
thank you anybody else want to declare
an interest
okay lawrence can i say that i
commissioned domestic violence services
for manchester city council
thank you thank you we will record that
interest from councillor carter thank
you
and councillor wright you'd like to
declare an interest
and councillor patel would like to
declare an interest be members of the
gmb
okay um is the mood
so mrs blackburn i think you want to
speak but can you use the chat facility
uh right thank you just just bear with
me
can we have a second for this motion
please councillor heinz
yes thank you um mayor um
i'll be also quite brief but i am very
eager to second
this motion and i too i'm hoping that we
can get some
cross-party support for it and we know
the incidents of domestic abuse have
increased significantly
throughout lockdown and that many people
haven't got the same
access to help and support that they
might once have had
and the fear is also that abuse is going
undetective
because people are more isolated and
prevent
friends family and importantly from the
workplace
um and both for the current
circumstances
and when we are finally out of lockdown
um as a large
local employer and leader in the
community it's incredibly
important that we do sign up to the gmb
domestic abuse charter
and that's with immediate effect and
as we heard in the recent council
meeting where we discussed
domestic abuse and we know that domestic
violence can
touch every aspect of a person's life
and
the lives of the children living in that
household
and whilst a person is living in an
abusive situation
their physical emotional and mental
health
can be significantly impacted um
and where this can sometimes affect
their capacity to work and it is
important that we have
um a an understanding and supportive
workplace and workplace environment
and and in the time following disclosure
of abuse there can often be huge
upheaval to home
circumstances and a reaction to trauma
so as an employer it's vital we ensure a
safe environment and a culture
that supports people in the workplace
that understands the issues connected
to domestic abuse and can link people
with sources of help
support and safety when it's needed
thank you
thank you councillor hines and thank you
for your patience and
counselor dr carr please
thanks chair i'll be very brief i've
spoken previously
in the chamber regarding domestic abuse
and the terrible impact that it has
it's right that we should pledge to
support the gmb charter so that any of
our employees who are going through
this horrendous terrifying experience
can know that their employer will be
able to help them
in a time of enormous need i don't want
to bring up again
any horrific examples of domestic abuse
coercion and control
but we all need to bear in mind that the
pandemic has left many victims of abuse
in even more precarious circumstances
and
in many cases living in a nightmare
without access to their normal support
i therefore hope that this important
motion will receive
cross-party support thank you thank you
councillor dr carr
councillor mrs blackburn please uh
thank you mr mayor um domestic abuse is
vile
unacceptable it must never be tolerated
mustn't be hidden
never swept under the carpet um support
to victims is essential
and unfortunately domestic abuse is
often replicated
in the next generation and support must
be given to families to eradicate
it perpetrators must be punished
the conservative group obviously abort
any form of domestic abuse and we will
be supporting
this motion thank you
thank you councillor miss blackburn um
i've got no other speakers and i'm
we've recorded all those members who've
declared interest
a lot of those being members of the gmb
so i'm going to put this motion
to the vote um
mr mayor well mayor i think i've pressed
the wrong
button there so can i withdraw
my against vote please replace it with a
four
i'm sure you can counsel hold and i
don't think that's an issue for us
um that motion has been carried
everybody that motion
has been carried um the final motion
this evening is relation to flooding and
severe weather
and is to be moved by councillor brophy
please
counselor brophy thank you mayor
so in moving this motion the aim is to
commit trafford
to a programme of joined up working with
the objective of protecting the borough
against the effects of flooding
and severe weather passing this motion
will mean the traffic council set up a
flooding resilience program of some kind
in conjunction with external agencies
and in consultation with local
businesses and residents
so due to the climate crisis the sort of
extreme weather that we have seen
over the last few years it will become
increasingly
much more common in october 2020 the uk
recorded its highest ever daily rainfall
the met office has produced research
that predicts more frequent extreme
rainfall over the next century
and the met office also highlights the
severe impact that extreme weather days
can have on our services
property and infrastructure we saw this
with the recent severe flooding across
greater manchester
and trafford caused by storm kristoff
so the motion creates a programme for
trafford that
gives flooding resilience similar
programs exist in
other local authority areas where severe
blood flooding
is more commonplace and these programs
make rapid
joined up responses that achieve
bringing together of all stakeholders at
regular meetings throughout the year
using this model trafford will be able
to consult with experts
plan for future instances of severe
weather and carry out improvements to
flood defenses
in concert with residents businesses and
service providers
councils across the country of all
political makeups
have similar working arrangements so
it's right that traffic should adopt
this approach moving forward
for example in calderdale the flooding
resilience program is overseen by a
board
whose members are drawn from across the
political perspective
the older councillors here may or may
not remember that in trafford council
october 2009 i first asked a question
about flooding as it became apparent
about the head of environment agency
said in a speech around the time that we
were going to have more
flooding and again in 2014 another
question
about um that ultimately led to to a
program of um that we we've now got on
the traffic website that
looks at our responses to flooding and
traffic so we've known this issue has
been around for a long time
and i'm delighted to move this motion
and i do urge all colleagues to support
it
so that we can have a proper and joined
up response to the future instances of
severe weather
that we're very likely to get under the
climate emergency that we're facing
thank you councillor brophy
i'm seconding that chair yes councillor
new gross you're going to second the
motion
yes
[Music]
you don't wish to speak councillor new
crush can i reserve the right to reply
please
absolutely that's fine thank you i'm
aware of an amendment and i've received
note amendment and will ask for this to
be moved i understand by councillor i'd
said councilwoman said
thank you thank you man yes sir
the events around the build up in the
days and weeks before stone for
pissed off was certainly like nothing
i've seen in my lifetime
indeed uh sections of my own ward run
high alert for potential evacuation and
set to life
and we were just within a few
centimeters of this actually becoming a
reality
thankfully the weather turned and it
didn't
happen i can say also having been
involved in the emergency planning
meetings during that period
that anything and everything that could
be done was done
i cannot praise enough everyone who was
involved with
traffic staff partners or volunteers
for the help and support they gave in
that time of crisis
and we have therefore amended the motion
to more
fully reflect this whilst there were a
number of flooding issues across the
border
our first an overriding priority was to
deal with the threat to life
saving people's lives was rightly our
first and foremost priority
with climate change events like this
will become more frequent
and work around this is already underway
albeit
informally we are therefore happy
support emotion reflecting this work
however
it does need a friendly amendment to
help reflect the structures
we are now putting into place to support
the strategy
and we trust that you would agree that
this makes sense
for this to be part of our overall
climate change work
now therefore in look at the time i'll
therefore urge
all members to support this friendly
amendment and the motion once amended
as a good way forward to help engage our
partners and our communities in this
vital
and essential piece of work thank you
mayor
thank you councillor said is the
amendment seconded
it's his secondary chair and just in
doing so um
just want to um with council's
permission just change one word
in there um please check but where we
have
changed climate emergency to climate
change just to
um reverse that and change that back to
to climate emergency
um effectively semantics in terms of
what it means for the motion but but
fair enough that some parties would
prefer um that form of
wording thank you thank you councillor
weston
um members wishing to speak and we are
running late everybody so if you can
make your comments brief um councillor
new grosh
thank you chair um i with the news that
i've just heard from andrew weston
council western my apologies
uh i am going to withdraw my request to
speak on that because the one word that
stood out by a long shot was the
minimization of this by
removing the emergency there are other
areas that i had
concerns um but that was the one
sticking point for me i'm going to
withdraw that
my my request to speak and thank you
to the for the small change there thank
you councilman
councillor coggins
thank you chair i'll also be brief and
we in the green group will be supporting
the motion
and um and our thoughts were very much
at the time uh with with those
uh under threat of flooding and indeed
those who did have to evacuate
in trafford and elsewhere and we also
will be supporting the labour amendment
having spoken to
senior officers involved um i'm aware of
of how really extraordinary this event
was and um
and the difficulties that our teams were
under um
and as others have said i think the um
the
um structures put forward in the labour
amendment are preferable to the to the
originals just for
for practical reasons um i did want to
comment also on the
labour's proposal to take out the phrase
climate emergency and replace it with
climate change um
we did have all party sports declare
climate emergency and
it isn't about semantics language does
matter the difference between something
merely changing and something being an
emergency
is a massive massive difference now i've
spoken a number of times about the need
for a change of mindset and real
culture change throughout your
organization and i do think actually
would be helpful if the council adopted
a habit of just
consistently and more or less only using
climate emergency or climate crisis
and really abandoning as many groups and
um and press organizations have done
abandoning climate change
and what slightly worries me even more
is the fact that this wasn't just a slip
this wasn't just something that was
drafted and they didn't think through
the wording
there was a deliberate effort to take
that word out and put it back in again
and i would like to ask cancer outside
if he would like to comment as
um proposing the most the amendment and
why he went to the trouble as the member
responsible for environmental services
why he went to the trouble of taking out
that word emergency and had a preference
for
for change thank thank you
councillor evans please
busy looking for the part where it's
been taken out so apologies for that
thank you chair i'll i'll be slightly
brief but not quite as brief as
everybody else
there's certainly an issue with flooding
along the ferryworld brook in template
and this has been recognized for years
and i have been working
with officers for years and i would like
to thank the office i know we've had
tens of thousands of pounds spent about
on a collapse
culver on the beach fields and i'd like
to thank the offices for the response
during
the because this the the first uh
emotion so
suggest they didn't respond well our
officers responded
superbly and trafford leisure responded
superbly and i'd like to thank them for
that but then moving on i'll take this
opportunity to thank sir graham brady
network rail and the environment agency
and our officers again for some
subsequent work
because network railing are putting in a
permanent pumping station
in timperley which is going to empty
into
the ferry well brook what we've managed
to do is get the flow of that pumping
reduced by 50
because obviously it could well have
exacerbated it the environment agency
have checked that
so that's been installed in village ward
so certainly support
the i probably would have would have
supported the motion certainly support
the amendment and we need to be looking
at this
specifically and simply so thank you for
this opportunity
you're on mute lawrence
thanks for that council western you'd
like to come in
thanks chair yeah as the um executive
member with responsibility for
sustainability and climate change i'll
respond to
councillor coggins point i i when i
describe it as semantics i
recognize the fact that councillor broke
he alluded to issues
more than 12 years ago or 12 years ago
as being problematic that was before
anybody was talking about a climate
emergency these are ongoing issues that
have been around
for years yes they are getting worse
yes that is as a result of climate
change we can use the language of
climate emergency if you feel more
comfortable
but just to be incredibly clear this was
not intended to minimize the issue
it was to recognize that this is a
longer term problem that actually
outdates that terminology
and and this is something that that we
have faced
on an increasing basis exacerbated by
the ongoing
climate emergency yes but as a result of
climate change
for decades and so i don't consider it
some sort of deeply offensive
um issue deserving of the sort of
ticking off that we just endured
councillor cobbins and i have to say to
you it is becoming slightly tiresome
to be consistently eluded
that things only happen in this council
chamber because we have green members
and it is just not the case that we
require you to be telling us
that if we don't call it an emergency we
won't do anything about it
we declared a climate emergency in this
council with all party support not
because we have green councillors
but because all members chose to support
that i declared a climate emergency in
greater manchester
not because we have green councillors in
trafford
but because that is what i believe and
frankly
we can debate whether it's an emergency
or a crisis
but what all of it is is climate change
and so when i said it was semantics
i stand by that statement and i
appreciate that it makes
you feel uncomfortable but as long as
the actions are there
which the amendment clearly documents i
think we can move forward
on that basis and i have to say that
fixating on these sorts of things
are in my view unnecessary as long as
the actions are there that the council
needs to take
thank you chair thank you councillor
weston
um i'm going to let councillor ad said
come back and he's
he's asked to come in count out if you
can be brief yeah i will be there brief
uh
thank you it's just because obviously uh
i was named there uh
one of the councils but when when i
wrote the amendment it was pure on the
grounds that this is to do with climate
change around the world that's all it
was technical wording unless council was
an outline there was no intent to uh
change anything or deal with that i'm
quite upset actually work with the way
that council probably has suggested
we're trying to undermine this
and suggest that that we had all tv
motors that's simply not the case that's
what the council western's comments make
it around that center which was subject
nonsense suggests that this was
deliberate so i hope that she would have
really
humor to take those comments back it's
just purely talk about climate change
around the world which is what the
motion was to do with thanking me
thank you counselor i had said counselor
bro for you have the right to reply
since you're the mover of the main
motion would you like to reply
yes i would so i'm really pleased that
the
motion um is getting all party support
i'm really really pleased about that um
so
um i'm grateful for the comments about
timperley as well i've been aware of
issues in
my own world of temporary for a number
of years and have studied the
environment agency flooding maps
and some of the places that are flooded
are down for
once every hundred years and i think
that's the case in village ward as well
but what used to be once every 100 years
is now every 10 years so it's quite
clear from reports we're receiving as
councillor wesson outlined in his speech
that these issues were known about 10
20 years ago the trouble is that we've
all been quite slow to react
and now we have got the stage of it
being an emergency as is in the original
motion
as councillor goggins pointed out and
the fact that we all agree on that we do
face a climate emergency
and to me the wording is important that
this emergency
is now here due to climate change so i
think um
we're all we're all happy with that i'm
very grateful that wording has been put
right
um so thinking about the amendment um
i think um what the liberal democrats
were kind of neutral about the amendment
i think we're quite happy with our
original motion
and um i'd be just happy if
all of traffic council could support the
motion um
amended or not amended if we get some
proper action on
flooding i do agree with the comments
about our officers as well
our officers do work hard it was in
because of the
extensive flooding that we had almost
everywhere
that a lot of the agencies were
ill-prepared that wouldn't have been the
individual staffing
problems or to do with this individual
staff it's more the policies that were
in place
at the time didn't allow for the
response
as it should have been to support
residents and that's basically because
we are in a climate emergency
and it's it's serious it's here it's
going to be ongoing and once we've got
past covid
facing issues like flooding and the
impact of climate change and the climate
emergency
this will be what we'll be supporting
our traffic residents for
so passing this motion is a start to
make sure we get all the agencies
working together
and and let's all put our backing behind
this in traffic council
thanks very much mayor thank you
councillor brother i'm going to put the
amendment to the vote now
that's the amendment
so the amendment has been carried
everybody the amendment has been carried
and we've had substantial debate on this
um
i think we can go that becomes the the
main motion i think we should just go to
the main motion i think we do need to
have a vote
um so we'll go to the main vote and um
the amendment becomes the substantive
motion
so the amendment stroke substantive
motion has been carried everybody that
has been carried
that concludes uh this evening's meeting
everybody can i just say thank you to
all those retiring counsellors
this evening um being a council
is hard work we all know that and um
thank you for all the time and effort
you've put into it and
we're all very very grateful i'm sure
the residents of trafford are
thank you everybody and i hope you
enjoyed the rest of your evening good
night everybody
thank you thank you mayor thank you
chair thank you